So now we begin on four
classes on number theory.
The purpose of taking it
up now is that we're still
practicing proofs.
And number theory is
a nice self-contained
elementary subject
as we'll treat it,
which has some
quite elegant proofs
and illustrates contradiction
and other structures
that we've learned about.
A little bit of induction, and
definitely some applications
of the well-ordering principle.
The ultimate punchline
of the whole unit
is to understand the RSA
crypto system and how it works.
Along the way, we will--
today, actually-- establish
one of those mother's
milk facts that we all
take for granted about unique
factorization of integers
into primes.
But in fact, that's
a theorem that
merits some proof as an
example, and the homework
shows where we exhibited
a system of numbers
which didn't factor uniquely.
And finally, we will be able
to knock off the Die Hard
story once and for all.
So let's begin by stating
the rules of the game.
We're going to assume all
of the usual algebraic rules
for addition and
multiplication and subtraction.
So you may know
some of these rules
have names like
the first equality
is called distributivity of
multiplication over plus--
of times over plus-- and
then the second rule here
is called commutativity
of multiplication,
and here are some
more familiar rules.
This is called associativity
of multiplication.
This is called the
additive identity.
a minus a is 0-- or
actually additive inverse.
0 is the additive identity and
minus a is the inverse of a.
a plus 0 equals a is
the definition of 0
being an additive identity.
a plus 1 is greater than a.
So these are all
standard algebraic facts
that we're going to take for
granted and not worry about.
And one more fact that
we also know and we're
going to take as an
axiom, if I divide
a positive number-- sorry.
If I divide a number a
by a positive number b,
then when we're talking about
integers, what I'm going to get
is a quotient and a remainder.
What's the definition of the
quotient and a remainder?
Well, the division
theorem says that if I
divide a by b, that means if
I take the quotient times b
plus the remainder I get a.
And in fact, there's a
unique quotient of a/b
and there's a unique
remainder of a/b
where the remainder--
what makes it unique
is the remainder is
constrained to be
in the interval greater
than or equal to 0
and less than the divisor b.
So we're going to take
this fact for granted too.
Proving it is not worth
thinking about too hard,
because it's one of those facts
that's so elementary that it's
hard to think of other things
that would more legitimately
prove it.
I'm sure it could be
proved by induction,
but I haven't really
thought that through.
OK.
A key relation that we're
going to be looking at today
is the relation of
divisibility between integers.
So by the way, all of the
variables for the next week
or so are going to be understood
to range over the integers.
So when I say number,
I mean integer.
When I talk about
variables a and c and k,
I mean that they're
taking integer values.
So I'm going to define c divides
a using this vertical bar
notation.
It's read as divides. c
divides a if and only if a is
equal to k times c for some k.
And there are a variety
of synonyms for a divides
b, like-- a is a-- a
divides c-- sorry--
c divides a is to say
that a is a multiple of c
and c is a divisor of a.
OK.
Let's just practice this.
So 5 divides 15?
Well, because 15 is 3 times 5.
A number n divides 0.
Every number n divides 0.
Even 0 divides 0, because
0 is equal to 0 times n.
So 0 is a multiple
of every number.
Another trivial fact that
follows from the definition
is that if c divides a, then c
divides any constant times a.
Well, let's just
check that out, how
it follows from the definition.
If I'm given that
c divides a, that
means that a is equal to k
prime c for some k prime.
That implies that if I multiply
both sides of this equality
by s, I get that s a is
equal to s k prime c,
and if I parenthesize the s k
prime, I can call that to be k,
and I have found, sure enough,
that s a is a multiple of c.
That's a trivial proof,
but we're just practicing
with the definitions.
So we have just
verified this fact
that if c divides a, then c
divides a constant times a.
As a matter of fact,
if c divides a and c
divides b, then c
divides a plus b.
Let's just check that one.
What we've got is c
divides a means that a
is equal to k1 times c.
And c divides b means that
b is equal to k2 times c.
So that means that a plus b
is simply k1 plus k2 times
c, where what I've done here
is used the distributivity law
to factor c out and used
the fact that multiplication
is commutative so that I can
factor out on either side.
OK.
Let's put those facts together.
If c divides a and c divides
b, then c divides s a plus t
b, where s and t are
any integers are all.
So a combination of two
numbers, a and b, like this
is called a linear
combination of a and b--
an integer linear combination,
but since we're only
talking about
integers, I'm going
to stop saying integer
linear combination
and just say linear combination.
A linear combination
of a and b is
what you get by of multiplying
them by coefficients s and t
and adding.
OK.
So we've just figured
out that in fact
if c divides a and
c divides b, then
c divides an integer
linear combination of b.
When c divides two numbers,
it's called a common divisor
of those two numbers.
So we could rephrase
this observation
by saying common divisors
of a and b divide integer
linear combinations of a
and b, which is a good fact
to just file away in your head.
Now, what we're going
to be focusing on
for the rest of today is
the concept of the greatest
common divisor of a and be,
called the GCD of a and b.
The greatest common
divisor of a and b
exists by the
well-ordering principle,
because it's a set of
non-negative integers
with an upper bound.
Namely, a is an upper bound
on the greatest common divisor
of a and b.
So as we did in
an exercise, or I
think in the text, that implies
that there will be the greatest
one among all the
common divisors,
assuming there are any.
But 1 is always
a common divisor,
so there are
guaranteed to be some.
Let's look at some examples.
The greatest common
divisor of 10 and 12.
You can check.
It's 2.
Mainly because 10 factors
into 2 times 5 and 12 factors
into 2 times 6, and the 6 and
the 5 have no common factors.
So the only one that
they share is 2.
The GCD of 13 and 12 is 1.
They have no common
factors in common.
You can see that
because 13 is a prime,
and so it has no factors
other than 1 and 13,
and 13 doesn't divide
12 because it's too big.
So it's got to be 1.
The GCD of 17 and 17 is 17.
That's a general phenomenon.
The GCD of n and n is always n.
The greatest common
divisor of 0 and n
is equal to n for
any positive n.
That's because everything
is a divisor of 0
and it means the GCD
of 0 and n is simply
the greatest divisor of n,
which is of course n by itself.
One final fact to set things
up for the next segment
is to think about the GCD
of a prime and a number,
and it's either 1 or p.
The reason is that the
only divisors of a prime
are plus/minus 1
and plus/minus p.
So if p divides a, the GCD is
p, and otherwise the GCD is 1.